today on our show the dawn of Justice is
coming all over your face neck and chest
right here on fat man on Batman
hey it's us man what up welcome to fat
man I'm Batman I'm Kevin Smith mark
barnard we got a metric [ __ ] ton of DC
to throw at these people today I know
why why because you were on the network
television's last night Oh Marc do tell
sometimes that like somebody texted me
in there would you want [ __ ] TV last
night and I was like ah no maybe they
reran clerks or something and she's like
no [ __ ] I was oh yes I guess yeah so
we talked about DC and Marvin Marvel Wow
DC and Marvel went head to head is they
always do last night
DC I'm on the CW with the flash returned
flash returned they had a special
previewing legends of tomorrow yes and
then the dawn of the Justice League
which was this wonderful half an hour
it's coming we're open the doors and
essentially was a nice sweet package to
remind people that Batman V Superman is
coming Wonder Woman is shooting and they
gave him footage which is [ __ ] nuts
and it's all over the internet this
morning but then thirdly which was even
[ __ ] louder there's a sonic boom last
night kids all across those internets
and trending everywhere was suicide
ejaculate just I have seen the trailer
and I believe I spoke about it here you
tell us
mark barnard in' what did you - give him
a goddamn [ __ ] single even the one I
[ __ ] loved it I really did it is also
kind of clear that right now we're in
the in the post guardians of the galaxy
trailer world where the job of these
trailers are - like he/she was fire
she's just crazy he's the greatest shot
in the world how are they a team yes and
then add to that your favorite [ __ ]
song from the year whatever like yeah
from the year you what is the galaxy had
all of those songs this one and this one
stylistically picks one thing it's that
on and it's a [ __ ] doozy they picked
bohemian yeah totally I mean guardians a
I've seen Google chock it all over
this one was absolutely just is this a
real life or is this just fantasy
it was [ __ ] it was pretty damn
magical man and they when I saw it when
we shot the special it was like
heightened security it was on a toggle
toggle whatever [ __ ] and like after a
dude literacy riously and once we
watched it it burned out like you didn't
see it wasn't like Mission Impossible
but like they were so secure about it
and then afterwards I signed an NDA
about not even saying what the [ __ ]
song was wow they were tight about and
good with good reason like you saw that
reaction online give us a two-shot you
saw that reaction online man like there
ain't anybody gone like [ __ ] this movie
now it's grabbing everybody maybe I've
seen some places online saying best
comic book movie super ear trailer ever
the bar has been raised and stuff like
that so last night that DC you know the
dawn of the Justice League was just a
backdoor pilot for Suicide Squad trailer
man think about they devoted a half an
hour of network as Mark pointed out
screen time to debut a trailer more of
that [ __ ] less of everything
else take [ __ ] programs off the air
so that every week I'm not even the
Yunnan spigot once every quarter they
should and it doesn't even have to be me
as Ozai and angling for a job but I do
it every day
[ __ ] oh my god but like it they
should just be like anytime I got a
trailer mm-hmm [ __ ] put a TV show
around he owned a network throw it up on
CW I don't know the ratings were but
like [ __ ] they own the internet last
night yeah buzz the hype and [ __ ] like
that you could just dump a trailer you
know on the interwebs or whatever you
know when you do at a Comic Con there's
a big [ __ ] to do about it and then
whether it leaks out or not but instead
of like with two event eyes this [ __ ]
yeah and you have two event eyes a
trailer that costs as much as that movie
I mean the movie the movie costs
whatever cost but getting that song
alone for the trailer really [ __ ] dude
that ain't cheap queen is not cheap no
especially with their like we pretty
much want to play almost the whole song
and we're gonna hang our hat on your
[ __ ] song and vice versa like the wait
at Wayne's World
and Bohemian Rhapsody were together in
the 90s we're gonna be that now this is
not just a needle drop this is a [ __ ]
like boom this is all us now thank you
very much and I would if I had like I
can't even [ __ ] fathom dude like
easily you know
don't call unless you starting in a
million like feels like that and it's
not like that's a favor because remember
hearing tales of Cameron Crowe when he
was making almost famous was literally
calling Jimmy Page like can I use that
Led Zeppelin songs on y'all right really
yeah because he covered them while as a
journalist for Rolling Stone
you see how sad the music relationship
he was married to Nancy yeah Wilson she
was one of half of heart she was half of
she was that she was the redhead half of
heart yeah but you know like that was
absolutely this guy like I need this
music for my movie we do not have the
money to pay everybody what they should
get for it so can you please help me
because this is all about the music and
they all just kind of like yeah alright
sure can't imagine like Warner Brothers
like can we appeal the better we have
that suffering I don't think that
character then no that's just an ATM and
like putting that song with those images
dude i sat there and watched it with my
[ __ ] kid my kids creeped me out she
cries at these Suicide Squad trailers
and I'm like you don't like it and she's
like it's true it's it's a transcendent
resplendent experience for us so she'd
been watching the first one to death man
and so we watched it like you know I cuz
I told her about when I shot it I was
like I've seen it it's it's amazing so
last night when the special aired man we
watched it together and I watched half
the trailer and the other half one eye
on the trailer one eye on the kid who
was just and then the tears came dude
like and not for any and she's not like
I've loved these characters forever like
something else is going on in the market
and the mix of that movie like it's
gonna make a lot of [ __ ] money it's
like a lot of money like you know I'm
Batman V Superman is gonna make a lot of
money but this might [ __ ] bookend it
man like what a smart choice and when
they first said this I was like wow
really that's what you want begin with
so alright so strong I watch
with my wife who is not quite that
person she indulges quite a bit for me
so we watch the trailer games there all
right who's that
Joker I guess he napped them another
Joker Harley Quinn all right we get to
the final credits she's a great pause is
that Scott Eastwood she living watching
the names accreditor he's a handsome man
that's who she paused who she paused I'm
like Scott Eastwood Cellini's woods kid
somebody else like brought him up on
Twitter last night they were like still
don't know who Scott Eastwood but did
you get any inside info they asked me as
if I remember to ask Jeff Johnson who
nobody knows he's like no clue did you
see him in the trailer I didn't
I also she did she saw me producer Matt
key you see that holy [ __ ] man there's a
scoop nice
rumor as if you didn't hear that was
Scott Eastwood son of Clint Eastwood and
yes we'll be playing Slade Wilson
just a rumor right in here dear first we
heard from Matt but that's and that
would set him up to play Deathstroke the
Terminator would they call him The
Terminator old-schoolers
my god we first met Deathstroke we knew
him as the Terminator yes
you remember him in the Judas contract
Judas contract as DC Books great [ __ ]
Teen Titans DC book but there's like you
go back and look at the Judas contracts
I remember reading it then and even now
there's like a moment in that book where
it's in more than inferred that Tara the
Titan is having an affair with with with
Deathstroke who is why yes
what part of team Titan is missing an
English it's kind of weird man it's very
you know comics dude you wouldn't get
away with that today
it's crazy
all right so Suicide Squad yes [ __ ]
huge it's gonna be fantastic boy oh boy
this movie needs no help whatsoever
Danette look huge like helicopters
strafing runs Mario Robi gonna be a huge
star I mean she already is but like this
is this is her canonization like anyone
who stepped up to bat as Harley for the
first time was gonna have a [ __ ] ton of
attention this may be perfect casting
yeah although I've read today mark and
Hollywood Reporter ah right right here
this week's Hollywood Reporter yeah with
the room girl brie Larson on the cover
yeah big Sundance talk look at this dude
that's me and my [ __ ] kid happy
family we're going to Sundance and like
hours 48 hours to to do what should we
call it the premiere of yoga hosers but
there's something in this article like
you know I I did my interview and she
did her interview we didn't do it
together
so I've read the article and there's
something in it that I was like kid like
had you told me we're gonna say this I
would have been like hey be cautioned
better this is a quote from my kid can
you do it as if George Lucas was reading
it I could to me growing up in the
Hollywood Hills Harley had planned on
becoming a professional basis when she
wanted to do music I could only take her
to gigs and buy her [ __ ] but that's
about it
says Smith that's me then I was like you
like acting I know a thing or two about
that
now her ultimate goal is to play the DC
Comics villain that is her literal name
steak steak sake well I make some named
steak man mistakes called Kevin named
segment the Joker screw loose companion
who will be played by Margot Robbie in
this summer Suicide Squad okay this I
didn't know I've known this kid [ __ ] she
popped out the [ __ ] shoot I was the
first one to see her next to the goddamn
doctor this is the first time I'm like
that's your life goal is to play Harley
Quinn because your name Darla Quinn but
I didn't even listen to her [ __ ]
quote I will not leave this earth
until I play Harley Quinn she says the
Assurant is that only a sixteen-year-old
can pull from your father don't say
things ever out loud to the press come
back to [ __ ] haunt you that's sweet
she wants to play Harley Quinn so
obviously not this gym margot robbie
ain't got nothing to worry about
but you know kids 16 just seems like
they were booting these movies every 10
minutes so you might have a [ __ ] shot
at one you know I'm just saying like
season seven of Flash
okay man from a little woman to Wonder
Woman Wonder Woman they showed Wonder
Woman footage I saw it back when we did
the special man I was like Wonder Woman
out of [ __ ] horse is crazy
I don't like action it looks great it
looks it looked it remind me a lot of a
lot of the wrong word but the period of
it reminded me of Captain America the
First Avenger
I liked her non Wonder Woman look with
the glasses or Eliza Doolittle Diana
Prince oh and the fact that they're
doing it across a couple generations
like it looks like they're starting her
story in thigh mascara and then she
comes to man's world during the World
War one yeah and I guess keeps coming
back and there's a shot and I don't
think it was like edited like to do this
but there's a shot in the show where
she's looking back at Bruce Wayne and
she gets into a car and takes off from
that same party where right Superman is
and stuff so like what is the story
there had his he met her as Batman Bruce
Wayne met Wonder Woman before is this
the first time I don't know but it would
be actually kind of fascinating to play
her like this immortal character who's
just been like tipping through history
and checks in on the Justice League as
time goes on I'm for that that like kind
of great like dude like cuz honestly in
a world where over at the Marvel studio
they got they made Thor work that was
the toughest of all those characters
like like you know Tony Stark in the
soup science you gotta act smart money
Captain America strong dude it's too is
like I'm sitting here going Captain
America that's real he's [ __ ] frozen
and ice that's stupid and weird too
but the idea of what's as far for yeah
god yes which you know they skate by
with like you know really magic religion
science who knows me yeah exactly so
this you know it's the if the work can
do that Wonder Woman can be there
Thor essential totally mythological
character where you know everyone else I
mean and again I don't know why we're
justifying it Superman like well you
gotta make Wonder Woman make sense now
cuz she's far she's from the old timey
days yeah it doesn't matter doesn't
really [ __ ] Wonder Woman just
hammering people with a shield looked
amazing and and then they showed and
it's crazy that they leaked footage that
early you know and said like they don't
leak it when they present it I guess but
it's nuts
like I think maybe they were one they
were also a little sensitive to the fact
that people wanted more Wonder Woman
from the Batman V Superman stuff like
that was the thing that people were so
excited about [ __ ] Wonder Woman holy
[ __ ] right now it's like he was not only
is she gonna be in this movie but or
shoot no whole Wonder Woman more like
they could have showed us more from
Batman V Superman which they didn't they
just showed us welcome the shots
definitely I was watching and going
that's knew I'd seen that who that's
knew there was a shot of him fighting
where I was like [ __ ] looks like like
it just looks like he's aren't that come
to life yeah it's crazy
but yeah this was definitely it feels
like this was the thing they were
leaning on was we have to remind people
how awesome Wonder Woman is how awesome
gal gadot is as Wonder Woman and just
sort of olay any fears that one might
have that it wasn't gonna work or they
weren't committed to it they took time
in the show you know and the
presentational style the show was what
are these characters about Geoff Johns
meanwhile you know we're both sitting
there knowing what all these cares but
this wasn't for fans I mean all the fans
definitely fans but it's more for moms
of fans who are like or husbands of fans
who are like I don't [ __ ] pay
attention to who's who now what is this
[ __ ] exactly it was a way in for
everyone else not for the hardcore fan
what the hardcore fans got out of it was
[ __ ] new footage proof actors sitting
in front of cameras going I'm in it like
who that that shit's happening that's
top shelf right there and then of course
the Suicide Squad trailer which was
amazing again this must happen all the
time all the time any time Marvel or DC
has a trailer to drop bill the special
around it [ __ ] yeah makes it huge
dude someone's already big makes [ __ ]
huge yeah that was my that was my
problem with the Marvel special the
Captain America's you watch that one I
sort of skimmed through it because it
turned out that there was no new trailer
at the Internet it was just like a sort
of Hosanna to the awesomeness that is
Captain America which is totally fair
totally he's awesome I got out to the
dude that made it is our buddy Zack this
is watch this director of that I believe
special the marvels but if you have an
American thing was Zack Knutson is that
Knutson Zack Knudsen is a guy we've
known for years man Zack if you ever
seen
clerks - he's kinky Kelly in the sexy
studies with the donkey he directed that
so I saw his name I was like [ __ ]
Zack and he had done the one worked on
one that you know the big Marvel 75th or
whatever special that ran last year that
trivia Scott Mosier cut isn't that
[ __ ] weird to that so that was cool
but it's very much like he was the
history of Captain America which
fascinating but it was like a
documentary but that gave us very little
newness other than people sitting in
chairs talking about how awesome Captain
America is including like some kind of
sweet stuff about like Jack Kirby and
Jack Kirby's son who watched it with him
and and and it was just like there's a
lot of sweetness around talking lovingly
about the character but I wanted like
you got a movie coming out also where's
your dick bring it bring out your Vulcan
marvelous dick the it's I believe I read
a story to where Steve Rogers is finally
coming back as Captain America in marvel
that was basically what they announced
and that that special was the cover of
Captain America Steve Rogers number one
it's [ __ ] cool - dude can you imagine
an hour long TV special on ABC I'm
noticing a new comic
that's so awesome man we live in an age
of wonder we're not the flying car and
hoverboards this is the future this is
where Marty McFly would show up now if
they were making that [ __ ] flower can
you imagine agent wonders dude they told
us other information or I told you and
today we're talking abou all over again
cyborg that we saw at a kid playing
cyborg ray Fisher we saw Ezra Miller
who's playing movie flash and we had
shot for those that you know follow this
sort of thing you know I'm a big [ __ ]
flash fan he was yes fan I've been like
talking about like why are they [ __ ]
we talked about this you know why the
[ __ ] would you create a new flash in
movies with all apologies mr. Miller was
a great actor but like you got a flash
audience and a flash grant is [ __ ]
phenomenal and so and we did a piece
where we talked about seconds they cut
it out and I was kind of bummed they cut
it out but the idea of hey man
DC is known for nothing if not a
multiverse so at which point I was like
could they [ __ ] cross over there's no
doors being left open and stuff like
that for you know like think about this
you can have
Ezra Miller be the flash and you could
also have Grant yeah be the flash
because there's a multiverse at work you
know or you could have had Ezra be Wally
West not anymore anymore no more flash
came back last night what we saw at the
end of before they went away from
Christmas we met while it was yes but
you know and all it's a little we're a
little ways away anything good for
Miller's like [ __ ] you guys we got the
job never mind anything had happened
shut your [ __ ] fat mouth I say who I
say Aquaman they had shot a Jason Momoa
stand there talking I met him on a plane
what a cool dude yeah could also rip a
plane in half I was honestly the safest
I start [ __ ] man he's gonna be like my
son in my mood
I saw some quote with him where he was
signing autographs at some convention
some reporter comes up is okay so
congrats and uncle man did you have to
take swimming lessons for the role and
he looked down to this guy he's like bro
I'm Hawaii all he said was I'm Hawaiian
bro and then just the like come on come
on
dear mom bro could you imagine grow up
he grew up in Iowa and Hawaii
so he's Hawaii with what every call that
I guess but you grow up around the water
in the water swimming and [ __ ] like that
even if you're not a comic book fan like
Aquaman is the water it's either Aquaman
of Submariner yeah that's it hmm ocean
terrorist okay but this guy grew up to
like be Aquaman that's bananas and as we
learned last week a murdered cast as a
mirror as mirror how do you think
they're gonna choose that's the thing
that moves gonna be wicked dude cuz it's
like everything's got to be under water
yep think about the amount of underwater
footage the amount of special facts
sharks him just [ __ ] commanding show
eat gosh dick yeah like that's my
version of [ __ ] uncle every shot is
an effect shot if it's all underwater
every shot is a shark Dickie shaman
charge Oh shark happen that's how you
turn all this [ __ ] never mind giving up
tattoos and muscles and stuff you wanna
change the [ __ ] common opinion of
Aquaman like he used less [ __ ] guess
what every time Aquaman strikes shark
bite your dick off he would be the most
he'd be more feared than Batman alright
man
Green Lantern was also talked about that
we didn't they announced we I was in the
special I got to ask him they announced
the Green Lantern Corps
corpse corpses now all the corpses of
the Green Lantern they're all dead the
Green Lantern Corps come I'm gonna be in
these movies man they're bringing both -
did you see the artwork did Jon Stewart
yes now there's [ __ ] smart this time
and learn from the past so it's gonna be
how and Jon Stewart and the rest of the
[ __ ] core is well I wonder if they're
gonna make a Green Lantern Corps movie
or if the Green Lantern Corps will
simply feature in one of the other
um if it's me mmm they feature until
everyone's like we [ __ ] love this and
then here's your own movie right like I
sort of feel like the Green Lantern
Corps at this point it's a bit like The
Hulk not just because of green but
because the Hulk is kind of best
deployed as a supporting character likes
true he can't really carry a movie and
we've seen them try twice neither of
which really worked either remove
Ruffalo though that's true that's true
but Norton not a bad actor
yeah good but I feel like a good point
[ __ ] yeah he was and that's a good movie
but you're right it's tough it's tough
ball powerful character because any
Justice League threat if they were like
you know [ __ ] rock monster by Lex
Luthor you just be like oh hell yeah
John [ __ ] giant boxing glove punches
him in the nuts and then a giant bubble
encapsulate them and he totally feels
like it's the you know break in case of
emergency
version which he I'd be calling I'd be
like Paul Rudd a man like I think we
should call I feel like I think we
should call the Green Lantern Corps very
much I mean we know Thor right we should
[ __ ] all four guardian magic guy what an
amazing time man and how awesome hats
off to the WB warner brothers meeting
and the CW and DC not just because like
they [ __ ] put me in it which was
lovely thank you but they're just doing
it yeah for doing it all I felt like
elated when I was shooting I felt elated
I was reading people's reaction on
Twitter like oh my god this got me so
excited and [ __ ] yeah it's exciting like
unapologetically doing it it's like
we're not hiding from it we're not gonna
tiptoe around we're not gonna drop a
trailer in the movies like here is a
night of television devoted to the [ __ ]
you love and they did it all without
ever being like and PS [ __ ] Marvel or
something like that
never even reference it they're like
we're bringing together heroes Oh first
time but usually heroes you know
change the channel Hawkeye it was I mean
that's the thing when you watch that
special you realize the brand name
recognition
mmm [ __ ] it through the roof like that
movies no way that movie don't make
[ __ ] a king's ransom man two billion
mom I don't know if a 2 billion yeah 1 1
to 2 billion is when I'm Michael
okay that's Batman V Superman dude I'm
gonna be Superman I'm gonna say those 1
6 once 1.6 billion yeah take that I'll
do some more bows take this yeah thank
you your lips to Batman's very long but
what a great night if you haven't seen
it hump the special down if you haven't
seen the [ __ ] trailer what are you an
idiot
come on yeah oh really anyway where have
you been it's amazing watch it you know
what go in the bathroom watch on your
phone because get ready to FAP it's
fantastic
why can't you be clean on this [ __ ]
show cause when why because if they ever
put on some TV we'll be clean the [ __ ]
rump foot on the Internet [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] dicks and stuff all right here
here's more news man speaking of second
dicks that's a bad segue yes because
this is amazing news we talked about
last episode the fantastic legends of
tomorrow which is debuted already as of
this taping right we don't know are we
it hasn't aired yet by the time you see
it as it will of Eric we talked about
last week to bring in Jonah Hex into it
yesterday this week to cast Jonah Hex
yes who is it
Jonathan Scheck that's your Jonah Hex he
was in that thing you do Josh Brolin's
like oh that's your Jonah come on yes he
was in that thing you do man some other
stuff I'm sure yeah I know he was on a
Sleepy Hollow recently it was like hey
it's the guy from the one-ders really
yeah and somebody else was like get me
[ __ ] Shaq get me check for hacks
check 4x um so he's gonna play Jonah Hex
man let's do a few more and then get
that [ __ ] out of here now actually blaze
10 Cloverfield Lane what the [ __ ] is
this about I kind of love the idea that
at some point somebody will make a movie
release a movie that we didn't know was
coming yeah you know like the way
Beyonce drops albums was at what [ __ ]
it's in them today like a like a pop-up
movie yeah literally and it feels like
JJ Abrams is slowly creeping towards
that it's like he shot a movie and put
out a trailer that nobody knew was
coming and you're like and let me tell
you something I was gonna pull it off
man let me hear yours
Manon Anna I was my pitch was a little
higher than yours
he's got the power he's getting good
I like a step bottom I always wanted if
I can come down on duties expressing
himself through art all right John
Goodman's in it yeah number so you got
my money [ __ ] you take all my money he's
[ __ ] a fantastic actor a great human
being his stuff out him in a movie
called red state but before I was in he
was he's been in like everything I've
ever loved I saw him in the trailer I
was a good god I was yelling at the
[ __ ] script my wife is like calm down
what is it what is it you think it's
connected I feel like it is or they when
they called it like 10 Cloverfield Lane
but it's it feels like it's the people
living in a bunker underneath the city
that had been destroyed and it's still
ruled by the Cloverfield monsters really
that's that's my read on the two and a
half minute trailer I watched the
trailer and I was like I'm going
regardless now I really want to go if
that's what the [ __ ] movie is that's
what it's related to it's like we're
part of Cloverfield yeah and who has
kids like apparently it had been long
enough that the kids don't know why
they're under there you know so it's
kind of like a big-budget room with
monsters oh my lord I'm so [ __ ] in I
know and if it's not that I'm gonna be
pissed but I wanted to be that did he
hide it in did somebody say he hid it in
the credits of Star Wars no it didn't
say I think so I thought somebody said
maybe it was just the end of the trailer
that they put up or something like that
but I had like a name and the dates or
something amazing yeah no hints or hide
nor hair of this you hear anything about
them no nobody did whispers in the wind
like he got a foot on heavy now it's not
him is one of buddy's bad robots right
there's no be a bad robot joint but I
don't know who's behind guys so busy
dude like seriously they're [ __ ] bad
robots making movies while they sleep
and not the way we're like these [ __ ]
movies are on sleep they're [ __ ] fun
but man we go to sleep because we're
like dazed on I'm tired they get up like
elves and make [ __ ] movies mm-hm and
then we wake up and they're like look 10
Cloverfield Lane yeah and like yes Joss
Whedon's shot you know much ado about
not
in between like shooting Avengers and
post on Avengers [ __ ] Shakespeare
that's very impressive I mean it's very
impressive but it's not like we had to
deploy thousands of special effects
artists to build this thing
yes we're like we all everyone came over
my house well I'll talk like Shakespeare
out of wine and we did Shakespeare like
we always do
yeah man [ __ ] 10 Cloverfield Lane got
my money yes please JJ [ __ ] JJ like
it's not stood like it's just crazy like
I'm when I got in his business like it
was never my name to replace
predecessors would be like I'm gonna be
the new dot dot dot if anything I wanted
to be the new how Hartley so yeah but or
Richard Linklater which now people go I
know him boyhood and stuff like that but
JJ like came in this business like man I
want to be the new Spielberg new Lucas
and he [ __ ] literally became it yeah
yeah which shows that you can dream and
do anything in this world man this is a
guy who wrote taking care of business
with Jim Belushi and people crapped on
him and now he's just like you know I
crapped a [ __ ] movie that sounds
negative I sneezed a movie the other day
10 Cloverfield Lane and it looks good
that [ __ ] trailer looks good I'm
should we pull the plug we [ __ ] well one
last story one last story jessica jones
got a second season yes come on and
punisher may get it first
that's no way to [ __ ] bury the lead i
know and throw it away like a it's the
rumor what bugs me about that is that
means we know that punisher ain't gonna
die in season two a daredevil
we were relatively sure that wasn't
gonna happen but you'd never know but
now sure all the tensions been removed
it's a flashback show does why you hire
[ __ ] mark barnard and man to write
your [ __ ] show's column column he's
smart there's all the news we got for
you this week folks thanks for hanging
out was here in the fat cave I've been
Kevin Smith mark barnard come join us
next week same bat-time same bat-channel
podcast calm also
like smarter slash Kevin Smith and
smarter back in there keV smart but
Marquis is smarter all that part
hey man it's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder